Randi's Sutton is a former law
enforcement officer who served with the
Las Vegas metropolitan Police Department
for almost 24 years he joins us from Las
Vegas this morning Randy can you tell us
how hotels coordinate with police in Las
Vegas yeah there's a very very close
synergy that takes place between hotel
security and the Las Vegas metropolitan
Police Department they work very closely
together because they're the problems
that take place in the casinos are
generally handled by their internal
security but anytime that there is a law
enforcement issue they then contact
Metro so there is there is a very close
relationship between these security at
the security apparatus and and Metro and
do they coordinate do they perform
drills together there are times when
they do work together to when they're
when they do like rehearsals for for
certain types of evacuations and and
each year there is there are events that
take place where there's a close
coordination for instance New Year's Eve
where we close the strip down and then
there's coordination like that as well
but keep in mind that many of these
security personnel are no longer armed
that there's been a movement over the
last 20 years to disarm most of the
security people so that there are some
armed some most are not though we know
that this shooter Randy was on the 32nd
floor of the Mandalay Bay Hotel is this
something that your department would
have ever prepared for a shooter up
above the crowd yes
well when I say yes these type of events
are planned for I mean you can only you
can only do so much but this is not
without the with this is totally within
the realm of contingency planning now
the way the shooter was identified was
not from the muzzle flashes but the
smoke detector in the room
went off from the amount of smoke that
came from firing that that fully
automatic weapon that's how they were
able to close in on him so quickly and
Randy when he talked about first
responders you're not only just talking
about law enforcement of course there's
medical first responders as as well are
the hospital's there in the surrounding
area equipped for such a mass casualty
shooting and obviously that's where the
focus is right now on all of those 200
plus victims who were still critically
injured and are being treated at the
local hospitals right and they're the
University Medical Center is the normal
trauma center where gunshot victims are
taken that UMC was overwhelmed
immediately with the number of
casualties so and then keep this in mind
that that the many of these these
injured were taken by civilians that
there simply weren't enough ambulances
to get there in time
so they were taken by civilians to area
hospitals literally all over the valley
now this this shooting went on for
somewhere in the area of 15 20 minutes
so that interfered with the getting the
first responders in to the area because
this individual planned this this this
horrific shooting immaculately I mean
when when you look at what his field of
fire was the way that he prepared
himself by having multiple firearms
by having the ability to have enough
ammunition to rain down hell on those
poor innocent people that were doing
nothing except enjoying themselves
I know chose his target well a Nick
Randy to go and reload the way he did
but I'm very interested in what you said
about muzzle flashes that it wasn't the
muzzle flashes that drew police to the
room that it was the smoke detectors
that went off in the room what does that
tell you about the amount and the kind
of firepower that this gentleman had in
his hotel room
well when when you fire even even four
or five rounds from a from a weapon like
that just four or five rounds that would
generate a fairly fairly high amount of
smoke but when you talk about the number
of rounds that he fired I mean literally
hundreds of rounds he must have prepared
with having multiple magazines loaded
and ready to to reload probably also he
had more than one firearm from from it's
my understanding so all he had to do was
drop it pick up another one and continue
his murderous assault on those people
random isn't a distance are we talking
about between
the hotel room where he was firing from
and the crowd below I'm gonna estimate
I'm gonna estimate about four hundred
yards and that would be that would be
within the killing range of that weapon
that he was using which is clearly
either a true assault weapon or it was a
weapon that was modified to become fully
automatic I don't know how this
individual would have obtained a fully
automatic or a number of fully automatic
weapons as they are heavily regulated
yeah but my question to you that was my
question to you about the gun laws as a
law enforcement officer is it easy to
get this kind of weaponry in Las Vegas
can anybody just walk in a store and buy
this no absolutely not but and I don't
know if these weapons that he had were
originally designed as fully automatic
or if they were modified you see if you
have the skill level and certain people
do you can obtain a kit which can take a
semi-automatic rifle and make it into a
fully automatic rifle so I'm not that
that's what this investigation they're
gonna have the ATF Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms part as part of this
investigation they're already involved
with the FBI Metro will be handling the
the majority of this investigation but
they will have to the ATF will be
examining those firearms that have been
that will have been seized to determine
a what if they were if they were
originally designed as fully automatic
they will also they have the ability to
track those firearms literally back to
where they were manufactured now were
they stolen were they modified did he
obtain them legally all these are part
of the the overall investigation and
these are questions that really have to
be answered all right Randy Sutton stand
by if you would appreciate your time so
far we don't have the answers to those
questions right now